okay okay okay leute ich weiß ich bin
titel gesehen wäre ich jetzt denkt was
ist das für ein spaß macht es doch
bestimmt nur für die klicks dann habt
ihr vollkommen recht aber es gibt auch
einen klitzekleinen sinnvollen grund
darüber mal ein video zu machen und zwar
weil ich jetzt schon von einigen leuten
gehört habe vor allem von jüngeren zum
beispiel meiner kleinen schwester dass
es wirklich leute gibt die ernsthaft
verunsichert sind wegen diesen killer
clown trend deswegen mag ich wollte man
darüber reden ganz vorne anfangen wie
entstand das überhaupt wieder um leute
angst vor clowns wie entstand dieser
hype und was soll man davon halten muss
man angst davor haben oder muss man
keine angst davor haben und da habe ich
eine sehr einfache und sehr sehr gute
beruhigende antwort ich habe mir dazu
ihre notizen gemacht
ich habe drei minuten daran gesessen
aber heute drei minuten mehr mehr kann
man auf youtube im jahr 2016 ich
verlangt weil er mich letztens in der
folgenden situation
ich studiere und da war ich bis nachts
spät in der uni nicht glaubt bis um zwei
uhr nachts oder so und meine uni liegt
seltsamerweise mitten im wald ich weiß
auch wie sich das ausgedacht hat diese
scheiße aber es ist so und von der uni
läuft man so einen verschlungenen weg
auf den ganz großen parkplatz und der
parkplatz ist halt nacht um zwei
menschenleer
niemand war da um es richtig krass
gespenstischer nebel in diesem moment
und das war so eine situation wo ich zum
ersten mal so ein unwohlsein hatte weil
ich mich an diese ganze killer clown
kacke erinnerte deswegen dachte ich mir
okay wenn es jetzt mir schon so geht und
ich bin 21
wie soll es dann jüngeren leuten gehen
die vielleicht 12 13 14 sind und denken
dass jetzt in jeder stadt in deutschland
irgendwie killer clowns hinter jeder
ecke lauern
was natürlich bullshit ist aber wenn die
leute angst davor haben dann sollte man
vielleicht versuchen den die angst zu
nehmen und das versuche ich mit diesem
video so ein bisschen zu machen
das ist zumindest presse irgendwo
sinnvoll ist fangen wir an menschen
haben ja irgendwo grundsätzlich so ein
bisschen angst vor clowns
es gibt ja leute die haben wirklich eine
phobie das heißt ja eine sehr
ausgeprägte angst vor clowns
das nennt man im fachjargon kubicki aber
eine suchmaschine mir gerade ausgespuckt
und das macht doch irgendwo sind bei
pflanzen eigentlich menschen die lustig
sein sollten und irgendwie haben leute
also bleiben dazu hinter dieser fassade
dass ein clown lustig ist noch irgendwas
übles zu vermuten deswegen gibt's
irgendwo neigung zu angst vor clowns zu
haben aber tatsächlich als historisches
beispiel für einen clown der über dinge
gemacht hat war john wayne gacy das war
ein serienmörder in den vereinigten
staaten
der ist als clown auf messen aufgetreten
und hat insgesamt 33 mensch
umgebracht warum erzählt es in dem video
in dem ich leuten die angst nehmen will
okay das hat aber jetzt für uns in
deutschland österreich und schweiz
nichts zu bedeuten
der typ ist 1994 hingerichtet worden
oder so also das ist eine ganz andere
sache und es hat mir deutschland
überhaupt nichts zu tun das ist nämlich
was wir uns überlegen müssen dann weiter
in der geschichte der clowns gab es ein
buch von stephen king das heißt es auf
deutsch und auf englisch und darüber
habe ich sogar meine hausarbeit
geschrieben von 15 seiten oder gezeigt
darum dass auch so ein clown sein
unwesen treibt aber irgendwie
übernatürliche kräfte und er macht
irgendwas in einer kleinen stadt
vielleicht haben paar von euch das buch
schon gelesen ist eigentlich gar nicht
so schlecht und vielleicht nicht so gut
wenn man angst vor clowns hat also
welche angst vor clowns hat dann lebt
von stephen king nicht der ganze trend
auf youtube und in den sozialen medien
ging angeblich laut n24 damit los dass
die youtuber matteo und jäger aus
italien vom channel dm frank productions
damit angefangen haben irgendwelche
clown cranks aufzunehmen war natürlich
sehr beschränkt von ihnen aber die haben
damit wahrscheinlich wie eine welle
ausgelöst
seitdem geht es seit august 2016 relativ
grund vor allem in den letzten wochen in
deutschland richtig rund in den medien
das ist jetzt seit längerem nicht nur
ein phänomen in den medien sondern es
hat auch mehr oder weniger tatsächlichen
bestand das heißt es gibt tatsächlich
fälle nämlich n24 spricht von 100 bei
der polizei gemeldeten fällen in
deutschland und darüber hinaus gibt
beweise dafür dass ein solcher als clown
maskierter mensch in rostock jemand mit
einem baseballschläger angegriffen hat
und so jetzt ist die große große frage
woher kommen die und es gibt bestimmt
einige leute da draußen die denken es
gibt so eine weltweite vereinigung von
killer clowns oder es gibt überhaupt
killer clowns als solche also
tatsächlich irgendwelche wesen die
aussehen wie clowns aber irgendwie übel
drauf sind und das ist es kann ich euch
sagen natürlich absoluter unsinn
sowas gibt's nicht woher kommen die
leute ist die frage die man stellen
müssen und das ist ganz einfach es fing
wahrscheinlich alles an diesen
italienischen youtuber nur mit
irgendwelchen youtuber die dazu geführt
haben dass diese killer clown kacke in
der öffentlichkeit aufmerksamkeit
bekommen hat dass man dann mehr oder
weniger viele leute gesehen und die
sache ist leute es gibt in jeder menge
von menschen die ausreichend groß genug
ist
arschlöcher und welche leute springen
auf sowas auch verkleiden sich als
clowns und anderen angst einzujagen und
so zu tun als gäbe es wirklich so etwas
wie killer clowns natürlich arschlöcher
dessen menschen denen komplett egal ist
wie sich andere leute für die einfach
sie denken können
denn irgendwann langes leben macht
endlich sind und dann springen sie auf
sowas auf dessen einfach menschen die
keinen anstand haben und überhaupt kein
mitgefühl keine empathie für andere
menschen sonst würde man so was nicht
mache
uns würde man sich nicht hinstellen und
leuten eine heidenangst ein jahren also
das geht halt nicht aber diese leute
sehen dass halten den media also es gibt
leute denen einfach egal ist was andere
menschen denken und die auch bereits in
anderen menschen zu verletzen
die sehen das die medien das killer
clowns im trend sind oder auf youtube im
trend sind und springen dann darauf auf
und denkt sich endlich habe ich mal was
zu tun ich den ganzen tag auf der couch
sitzen und besorgen sich ein verdammtes
kostüm und laufen durch irgendwelche
städte um leuten angst einzujagen das
sind die killer klar okay es sind keine
übernatürlichen wesen das sind keine
bösen tatsächlichen clowns mit üblen
absichten dessen einfach nur arschlöcher
denen es langweilig ist okay arschlöcher
den es langweilig ist das sind keller
klaus natürlich immer drüber nachdenkt
versteht man auch wie die ganze sache
sich verbreitet sei als es fing alles an
mit italienischen youtuber in zwei
weitere leute sehen das springen darauf
auch dass sie nennt wiederum vier
weitere leute springen darauf auf dass
den fünf weitere arschlöcher und
springen daraufhin so verbreitet dass
sich die ganze sache und irgendwann
denkt ganz deutschland jeder mensch muss
angst vor clowns haben danach war es
natürlich ist es absoluter bullshit das
weiß auch jeder mann hat irgendwo
vielleicht doch so eine unbewusste angst
aber ging die wollen wir heute vorgehen
es ist nämlich im großen und ganzen
sinnlose panikmache muss ein einzelner
mensch beispielsweise ein mädchen aus
münchen oder ein junge aus ostfriesland
oder ein anderer junge aus berlin angst
haben wenn er nachts vor die tür geht
dass irgendein killer klein auf in
zukunft irgendwann tut nein ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich warum es gibt ja viele
fälle in deutschen dieser berichtet
wurden ungefähr 100 stück bisher bei der
polizei war der stand in dem n24 artikel
den ich dazu gelesen habt warum muss ich
mir das selbst keine angst nach auf 100
ist auch so eine gigantische nummer 100
in deutschland deutschland noch nicht
gross 100 leute jetzt kommt aber die
statistik ins spiel
deutschland hat zum stand des ende des
jahres 2015 82 75 68 4 millionen
einwohner also sagen wir ungefähr 82
millionen einwohner
jetzt haben wir 100 fälle beobachtet
rechnen wir das mal aus welchen anteil
diese 100 fälle 100 betroffene an 82 mio
einwohnern ausmachen das ist eine zahl
die laute der 121 95 x 10.6 oder 000 000
1 2% umgerechnet sind das 0 0 0 0 1 2
prozent also 0 0 0 0 1 prozent was ist
das für eine wahrscheinlichkeit das ist
überhaupt keine wahrscheinlichkeit also
wie die wahrscheinlichkeit dass selbst
einem so was passiert ist so schwindend
gering da ist es wahrscheinlicher dass
ein mitten in berlin eine kokosnuss die
in den tropen runtergefallen ist und auf
seltsame art und weise in die
erdumlaufbahn geschafft hat auf den kopf
fällt und eine schlägt die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass einem selbst was
passiert ist so unfassbar gewinn und das
müsst ihr halt wissen zu hause die
meisten leute machen sich halt nicht so
gedanken über statistiken weil sie
irgendwie auf mathe keine lust haben
wollen sich denken mathe ist blöd aber
mathe kann manchmal auch gut sein zum
beispiel in solchen fällen wie gesagt
wir haben eine wahrscheinlichkeit von 00
00 12 prozent dass irgend einem
zufälligen bürger in deutschland so
etwas passiert versteh mich nicht falsch
aber die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ihr
morgen aus dem haus gehen vom auto
überfahren wählt ist mit sicherheit
höher würde ich jetzt mal so gefühlt
sagen abschließend leute eher daran
messen einfach irgendwelche dummen
arschlöcher die sowas machen das sind
keine bösen werden getrennt bald wieder
abebben und ganz wichtig die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es euch erwischt
ist so gering und im service halt
passiert euch selbst dann überhaupt
nichts also macht euch nicht verrückt
bis zum nächsten video schreibt gerne
feedback in die kommentare
und tschüss